you are not in kansas anymore
you are on pandora to me 3d is just like
color
uh it's just something that that adds
that heightens
the viewers awareness and sense of
inclusion in the action
it's not an end in and of itself so we
have to make it comfortable
involving and inviting it really invites
you
spatially into into the
the scenario that you're watching
i think there was a tendency to say if
you're going to do it in 3d you have to
do it differently you have to tell that
story
differently and you know at the end of
the day it's the same story and it's
told the same way
the more you become enamored of the
stereoscopic illusion
as a filmmaker and just want to play
with that
the less you're actually telling a story
i always believed that that 3d would be
would be stillborn uh broadcast
if you had to do a separate 3d
production a separate 2d production of
the same event
it was never going to make sense you had
to do an integrated production
and if that meant deriving your 2d feed
from the 3d camera from a single eye
or having your 3d camera piggybacked
onto a 2d camera it's really the same
thing
ultimately as long as there's still only
one camera operator having to light
artistically for two to three cameras
is really the problem it's not whether
you're in 2d or 3d
that's not true that's not your primary
issue in fact when i was shooting
multi-camera on on avatar it was really
just how do you make the lighting nice
for for three camera positions it's hard
to do i used exactly the same
aesthetic i always did when i when i i
operated the camera myself
i'm not looking at a 3d picture i'm
looking at a 2d picture i'm composing
for it
yes in the back of my mind i know that
if you're doing a kind of a dirty over
the shoulder
you don't let the person hang in and out
of the frame
they're in or they're out you know and
if you're
hand holding and you step behind them
you step decisively to that position
you don't kind of waver and let it float
on the framelit a few little rules
we went into it early on thinking oh
well we're going to have to reinvent how
we make films
that turns out not to be the case we're
just bringing new technology that allows
you to get
another result from your effort so right
now we're all about
3d ubiquity massive adoption and we want
to work with the a-listers
you know scorsese right 3d bring it on
i'll completely change everything you
know
all you know all integrated into my art
and of course he did went out and did
the best 3d photography
that anybody had ever done period
including including
ourselves working on avatar you don't
have to know anything about 3d we'll
stand behind the scenes
and either the cameras will do it for
you or we'll twiddle a few knobs in in
post-production
you don't have to worry about it just do
what you do just just just blaze with
the style that you know
and and we know how to make it good 3d